so this is the first in my series of dr
sandler's talk and talk um where i'm
going to answer some questions
uh dealing with philosophy or legitimate
politics or
maybe even literature who knows what
that are coming to me from vu users or
users
you only get two minutes to talk on vu
so i'm doing this in youtube so i can do
some longer
answers to the more involved answers to
these questions so the question that i
got asked
which i've got on the chalkboard is do
you believe in love after sight and this
is kind of an interesting one there was
also a follow-up question which
and then there was a follow-up question
that is sold does that having a soulmate
mean having a perfect marriage no
fighting harmony all of those are the
things i'm going to follow up on in
other videos
so
uh love that first sign well
think about what we can talk about with
this
is it possible can you fall in love with
somebody at first sight
yes i think that in fact you can we're
going to see
as we talk about it
um
we have to
qualify that a little bit because can
you fall in love with it with somebody
in in all the ways that we think about
being alone perhaps not
um
but here's another question think about
is it really desirable to fall in love
with somebody at first sight is that
something that we should hold out as a
norm and we do hold it up
because we see that coming up in a lot
of romantic
films and a lot of
stories and songs
so you know the question has to be is
this really a good thing do we do we
want to have people falling in love at
first if it isn't possible
and i do think that it is
possible
something that i would like to talk
about
before we go into that
we talk about love at first sight does
it have to be psyched
could it be carried out through some
other sort of medium think about the the
pervasive power
of our sense of smell and our gustatory
senses um
could those be a way
of getting to know somebody so to speak
and being attracted to them
immediately i think yes
as a matter of fact
odors smells sets are
deeply associated with those things that
tie in with us when we're talking about
about the kind of love that we're
thinking about love at first sight
desire attraction
appreciation
and openness to the other person
a
infatuation that makes us want to be
with them all the time
now it gets kind of interesting here
does it have to be sight
could it be maybe words
could it be
text
could it be
thought
think of siri cyrano version you know
again you know is this anything
scientific of course not we're using
literature this is the way we do things
in humanities we think about things
through examples
through
great pieces of art great pieces of
literature there are pieces of
philosophy very you know in the
historical situation of people think
about syrian diversion
what happens there roxanne falls in love
with somebody but it's not the young man
who's mouthings hear those words as it's
searing and she is falling in love with
him despite his
super long nose
through his words through his thought
through the character that's being
conveyed through all the other things
that come in and are conveyed through
language
now something like that happened with me
i'm going to tell you the story then
very quickly move on to these other
things
my fiance
my wife to me
um
she and i knew each other from high
school
and we lost touch for a very long time
and there's a whole story there but i'm
not going to go into it
suffice it to say we began writing to
each other through electronic means uh
eventually we we progressed as far as
using google chat so it was real time
and we fell in love with each other
without either one of the other knowing
or even i think fully suspecting that
the other might be
falling in love with them
through
the words of the other person through
what words can reveal
sometimes
words can actually reveal more of the
human heart
than any appearance can it in an
appearance as yes they're often
deceiving but actually
you know the eyes are the window to the
soul and the face does reflect at least
with people who aren't con artists does
reflect our emotions and our thoughts
and our feelings and our desires
we fell in love with each other
through words
wasn't love at first sight
that's hard to say that that's where we
have to get into these clarifications
we have to think of kinds of love
c.s lewis wrote a book called the four
loves and he was drawing on previous
people's work and
i'm not saying that this is the only way
to think about about these these
different distinctions about love but i
think that it can be quite useful i've
taught about this when i did an internal
philosophy class which is focused on
the question of his love and he talked
about four different kinds of love and
he used greek words for them did the
greeks always mean this when they used
the word euros or agape
no as a matter of fact the word agape
gets used in plato's symposium to mean
more or less the same thing as
but
it takes on a different meaning in other
texts and he talks about
affection historically
you know the sort of affection that you
have for
those who spend time with those who
become familiar with
you can have affection towards
things as well and towards animals
animals and affection towards each other
talked about desire
heroes
and
that encompasses a lot but you know you
think for example of boyfriend
girlfriend right that's that's an
example of arrows where when you see
somebody very attractive walking down
the street and you feel
something that we would call infatuation
or lost or sexual desire towards them
that's arose as well
friendship
feeling
here you have something that's
that's uh
quite different than arrows and
friendship is a very important kind of
love
you're not looking to get
the kind of thing out of somebody that
you are with heroes with your
but it is based on some sort of
commonality
as a matter of fact all three of these
are based on
commonalities
or on something that you derive from the
other euros seeks what it lacks as plato
says in the other person
then there's this sort of selfless love
that the latin is called karitas we get
the word charity from it
and the greek word for that is agathe
the term that's used in the new
testament often it's called you know
self-giving love or selfless love or
christian love or
you know by a lot of different names um
i prefer just to call it love and what's
different about this
is that it's not based on what the other
person is providing you or what you're
getting out of the other person or
even necessarily an appreciation person
you know aristotle talks about philia
and he talks about cases where you're
not actually getting something out of
the other person but you feel a sort of
sense of admiration for their good
qualities friendship in terms of
virtue and you might only be of use to
them or or you might be pleasant to them
they're not getting as much out of you
as you are from that
selfless love
this is the kind of love that christ
portrayed
um
that is often seen as being in spite of
the qualities of the other person
but you know a better way of thinking
about it
i would argue is thinking that it fully
appreciates
what the other person is
and it may be in spite of who we are you
know when my
wife to be loves me despite my faults
it's not just because she feels desire
for me or affection for me or because we
have all these things in common that
constitute friendship
i i think that it's also
because she
she makes a genuine effort to
love me
for what i am
even though i am what i am
um okay so now
think about this question about love at
first sight
what kind of love are we talking about
usually if we're thinking about
romantic love
we want to say
that's
desire that's erotic love
is it
is that all there is to romantic love
that's a question to think about
sometimes the movies make it seem like
that
but really you know what would the
movies that really really portray that
make it into the poor movies right
um the movies that
show lovers
coming to
learn about each other
to care about each other what's going on
there
something like feeling
is developing
or perhaps even
paying
or you know they feel affection for each
other i don't think that it's just
desire now the love and forsight part
that might just be desired
but what does that tell us that tells us
that love at first sight
is actually
incomplete
you can't possibly take in
the totality
of the other person
and who they grow to be with you over
the course of time in a moment
so
love at first sight here's where we
qualify
love at first sight
cannot actually mean the fullness of
love and include all of these things
could it even include what we call
conjugal
it could lead to it but it's not it
it's just the first loom the first
blossom of the season you might say
and here's the question that i asked you
in return
what do you want love at first sight for
what good is it going to do you it gets
you into things
but what really matters is what you do
after the first sight after the first
word
after
the
first encounter in the elevator who
knows what else you know the first
shared glance
that's where love grows and this leads
to the question about soul mates you
would only really notice somebody really
is your soul mate
through spending time with them
and through the development of these
other types of love they're waxing their
growth they're unfolding so
that is the answer to that question and
i'm going to follow this up by talking
about the
notion of soul mates in another video